[Musica]
ad alzata di mano
quanti di voi qui presenti in sala
pensano che qui per non essere volgare
uso un eufemismo pensano che la musica
pop di oggi possa essere definita
lassativa benissimo io faccio
esattamente questo quello quelli che
fanno il mio mestiere
vengono chiamati song writer
nell'accezione peggiore del termine
visto che avete alzato la mano pop
writers per quello che mi riguarda negli
ultimi anni ha avuto la fortuna di
scrivere con altri autori puri ma anche
con altri cantautori della cosiddetta
scena indie alcune pagine di repertorio
per alcuni interpreti della scena
musicale contemporanea italiana luca
carboni marco mengoni emma fedex
francesco renga alessandra amoroso e
tanti altri
ma così alla fine questo pop io uso due
termini che sembrano addirittura
altisonanti il minimalismo e
globalizzazione vi spiego subito
prendete qualsiasi playlist di spotify
dato che siamo nell'era dello streaming
ad esempio le top 50 di paesi diversi
nel mondo anche distanti tra loro
noterete una cosa incredibile che la
metà dei brani di queste playlist hanno
gli stessi accordi gli stessi suoni e
sembrano prodotte dallo stesso
produttore da un altro punto di vista il
maestro ennio morricone nel suo ultimo
meraviglioso libro inseguendo quel suono
scritto con arrestando de rosa parla di
musica di consumo con un linguaggio
molto vicino a quello della pubblicità
che tende alla semplificazione massima
del messaggio per vendere il prodotto
nel minor tempo possibile e usa
alcune parole chiave brevità
ripetitività incisività non a caso sono
parole chiave che si usano
forma canzone nel pop di oggi brevità
del gesso melodico ripetitività
incisività non a caso il ritornello è
l'inciso che deve essere orecchiabile
memorizzabile il tutto in un contesto
rassicurante riconoscibile e mai
perturbante dal punto di vista di noi
songwriter pop writers che quindi
facciamo musica l'abbiamo ad altri
questo modo di fare musica può essere
inglobato nella grande famiglia della
musica applicata ossia musica scritta in
funzione di altro o più nel gergo musica
su commissione questo per distinguerla
dalla musica assoluta che la musica che
nasce libera a livello creativo senza
scopi o destinazioni musica applicata
che è stata sempre criticata
basta andare alla fine per esempio alla
fine dell'ottocento nella belle epoque
francese ad esempio erik satie che è
diventato erik satie per la sua musica
assoluta
parallelamente scriveva musica su
commissione per circo e cabaret e per
questo veniva denigrato e deriso perché
il circo e il cabaret erano i luoghi più
bassi dell'arte ma torniamo a noi comuni
mortali
oserei dire normali io nel mio
piccolissimo mondo avuto sempre un
dilemma etico ed estetico su quale e
quanto fosse la mia libertà a livello
creativo
quando devo adeguarmi a questo
fantastico mondo che il luna park del
pop e quindi qual è la differenza tra
essere artista ed essere mestierante qua
si può essere liberi a livello creativo
in un posto pieno di limiti e
soprattutto se questi limiti non ci sono
qual è la musica perfetta per me vi
faccio vedere un'immagine questa è la
copertina del mio ultimo album come come
solista progetto dar dust è esattamente
come come io mi vedo sulla sinistra il
compositore che scrive dietro le quinte
nell'oscurità scrive musica pop per gli
altri sulla destra il compositore
inquieto in cerca sempre di nuovi
linguaggi
sia ben chiaro io avrei potuto rimanere
nel calduccio rassicurante nel mio
studio a scrivere canzoni no deciso di
intraprendere questa missione questa
missione chiamata d'arda questa mia
ricerca della della mia musica assoluta
per fare questo sono andato un po la a
ritroso a scoprire le mie origini
musicali io ricordo benissimo uno dei
lunghi pomeriggi quando vivevo ad ascoli
piceno era un ragazzino di studio di
pianoforte classico ricordo che stavo
proprio studiando una delle suite
inglesi di baker che era esattamente
questa in una pausa studio ricordo
accesi la radio e per la prima volta
ascoltare questo una sorta di epifania
la complessità polifonica delle cinque
voci di barche contro la serialità
minimalista di una di un arpeggiatore
dei kraftwerk e proprio dalla düsseldorf
dei kraftwerk a prendere l'auto bene
proprio per citare un loro disco sia
l'autostrada in tedesco arrivare alla
berlino alla berlino della mitica
trilogia di david hogg e brian eno
loiero selogie e poi a scoprire tutta la
scena elettronica è stato il secondo
così come negli anni successivi negli
anni zero a scoprire il dream pop lo
show che fino ad arrivare all'islanda
l'islanda di questo nuovo linguaggio
musicale dei sigur rós un linguaggio
fatto di spazi infiniti atmosfere
rarefatte dove trova luogo trova spazio
la voce angelica o aliena di john si è
proprio da quel pomeriggio che sono
partite le mie domande che mi hanno
portato anni dopo ad andare in quella
berlino e in quella reykjavik che avevo
immaginato e sognato ascoltando i dischi
e questo per trovare la mia libertà
creativa ho deciso che avrà impiegato
tre dischi per avere giusto per avere il
trip della mia trilogia personale uno
per ogni città uno a berlino mare chiavi
che il terzo non è oggetto di discorso
qui perché accadrà a breve andremo a
londra ho messo su un team di amici
amici creativi abbiamo sfidato il freddo
dell'islanda gli spazi questi spazi
infiniti fatti di di terra lava e
ghiaccio questo poi per andare in studio
a registrare a scrivere la musica lo
stesso a berlino abbiamo abbiamo
assaporato dorato direi gli odori
multietnici del quartiere di noi con per
poi ascoltare l'eco industriale delle
periferie di berlino per poi quindi
tutto questo per lasciarsi ispirare e
scrivere trovare un nuovo linguaggio
musicale
ecco per mettere insieme tutti questi
pezzi del puzzle quali erano le mie
origini musicali così distanti tra di
loro mi sono approcciato ad un concetto
che io trovo meraviglioso e unico che è
il concetto delle incongruità quando
avevo 10 a 9 anni mi sono da ascoli
piceno mi sono trasferito a roma per
studiare per studiare psicologia sapevo
che non sarebbe stata la la mia strada e
quindi ho deciso di iniziare una ricerca
per la mia tesi di laurea proprio in
psicologia dell'ascolto musicale che era
quello che mi interessava
secondo questa disciplina uno dei fulcri
fondamentali dell'ascolto della
l'esperienza dell'ascolto musicale è
proprio quello dell'aspettativa legato
all'attenzione vi spiego senza andare
nei tecnicismi può capitare per esempio
che durante l'ascolto musicale ci sia un
punto di partenza che può essere questo
per poi fare una bella passeggiata e
quindi si può andare qui
si può andare qui
quando si arriva a un accordo come
questo
l'accordo come questo che ha una
tensione fisica e matematica che il
vostro corpo
fisicamente ma anche oserei dire
inconsciamente riconosce si creano e
l'aspettativa
dove andrà a finire questa questa
passeggiata e così accade questo
passeggiata è finita dove ci aspettavamo
ma può capitare ad esempio che che
accada ciò che non ci aspettiamo per
esempio passando dal dall'armonia
andando al piano della dinamica
facciamo una passeggiata con album da un
intro delicatissimo un pianissimo
distaccato di archi arriva un forte
orchestrale improvviso
non a caso la si chiama la sorpresa da
questa sintonia ci troviamo in un luogo
inaspettato che è quello della novità
nella sorpresa e c'è dell'incontro italy
incongruità che il compositore ma tutti
gli artisti possono usare per creare
vari effetti effetto drammatico effetto
grottesco effetto humour l'incongruità
lo è il luogo più bello dove sarà il
luogo dove i coraggiosi amano
avventurarsi dove coloro che fanno della
ricerca dello stupore ma anche della
probabilità di fallimento la loro la
loro forza ecco mi faccio ascoltare il
primo singolo di dar das la mia prima
non entro
riconoscibilissimo tradizionale di
pianoforte la mano sinistra fa un
movimento che è il cosiddetto basso
albertino
arriva questo arpeggiatore elettronico
che cresce cresce a livello dinamico
fino a diventare quasi
[Musica]
due luoghi totalmente diversi uno molto
più vicino a quello della della musica
classica che poi per citare un altro dei
miei miti si è evoluta fino agli inizi
del 900 per essere fruita in queste sale
da concerto dove si sta seduti immobili
e si ascolta con la testa e la musica
elettronica che nell'accezione più
conosciuta viene fruita con tutto il
corpo
ballando muovendosi nei club ecco
vissuto queste mie incongruità per
trovare la musica perfetta per me ma ho
capito che ovviamente non era la musica
perfetta per gli altri perché per
esempio per i puristi classici e è
banalmente musica ambient per i puristi
della musica elettronica e troppo
contaminata troppo per i puristi
dell'indy come fai ad essere credibile
con un progetto così se viene dalle
canzonette bene io non ho ascoltato
nessuno ho ascoltato solo me stesso
perchè la cosa meravigliosa che avendo
visitato questi luoghi che vi ho
raccontato ho ritrovato un nuovo bacino
di creatività che mi ha migliorato che
ho capito che se sei un posto pieno di
limiti puoi tornare nei luoghi in cui
sei stato libero ed esserlo imparare ad
esserlo in una stanza chiusa che al di
là di una di una pro di un ascolto di un
approccio l'ascolto molto cognitivo e
razionale che in base ai tuoi e gli
schemi e rata 1 scienza la cultura ti
permette di analizzare la complessità di
un brano c'è un altro piano di ascolto
che è quello dove voglio stare da quello
emotivo emozionale dove le incongruità
aumentano dove le categorie cadono e
soprattutto dove la perfezione non
esiste e perché poi tornando a noi la
musica perfetta non esiste la musica
perfetta è quella che tu sei ascoltare
grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]
già
[Applauso]
[Musica]